[Music]
oh the off season is a time for plenty
of optimism and that feeling is not
reserved to the fans the owners have
plenty of optimism as well for the
dallas cowboys 30-year owner jerry jones
believes that there is no tangible
reason why we shouldn't be better
than we were last year we are going to
have real scheme changes on offense
that's going to improve us i don't mean
to be trite we're going to make a big
effort to be better offensively we're
going to try to challenge the defense
more we're going to try to expand our
options and that over-the-top optimism
that setting of the bar even higher
chris at a time when jason garrett is
entering the final year of his contract
and jerry jones has made it clear he's
not giving the head coach a new deal
this year he's on notice of what is
expected and if if he doesn't give jerry
jones what jerry jones wants there's
going to be a new coach of the cowboys
in 2020. yeah it certainly seems that
way this time around this is not a oh
gosh it seems like
if they just are respectable jason
garrett will hold on to his job no it
seems like it's going to have to be
playoffs and probably win a playoff game
or something along those lines again uh
and i understand jerry jones
expectations too i mean hey uh this
dallas football team is talented there's
no doubt about that i mean when you just
talk about one of the best defenses in
football uh the dallas cowboys are up
there in that conversation right mike i
mean we talk about their defensive line
with demarcus lawrence they're deep they
got a lot of other players with tyrone
crawford malik collins you go down on
the list the linebacking core it's one
of the best in football the secondary is
one of the best in football and then you
go oh offense okay whoa they got one of
the best offensive lines in football the
running back of course amari cooper
along with it the big question is the
one thing you said
is the offense they gotta get more out
of the offense more creative plays more
explosive plays in the pass game which
we saw when amari cooper got there last
year and that's when dallas really got
rolling it took pressure off their
football team but they have to continue
to push themselves schematically with
the things they do they can be
predictable at times and rely on maybe
just physically overpowering every team
in football and that's just not going to
happen on a week to week basis in the
nfl so it is jason garrett kellen moore
i'm rooting for them and but they do
have pressure on them and they need to
make that offense work and go this year
you know dak prescott one of the guys
who they would like to sign to a
long-term contract but i think they
would like to do it on their terms if
prescott is going to drive a hard
bargain and there have been indications
that he will remember when you
interviewed him at the super bowl and
you tried to make the argument for him
doing a team friendly deal he gave me
the side eye he did he did yeah
if you're thinking about changing your
coach
do you eventually decide to just
postpone everything with prescott for a
year you get yourself potentially into
the franchise tag dance but you also
have the flexibility to say you know
what new coach isn't feeling as good
about dak prescott as the old coach did
and if we want this new guy to be the
coach maybe we let the new guy go get
his own quarterback i hear that i think
that'll be a conversation that if it
gets down to okay the cowboys are
struggling in week 8 or week 10 and
they're not going to make the playoffs
that i'm sure that type of conversation
would go down in dallas so they're gonna
start thinking about their next move
what are we gonna do it coach you know
yes is uh dak prescott going to be in
the vision of this future head coach
whoever it may be uh so yeah a lot of a
lot of pressure on both sides here but
the one thing i'll say with dak prescott
and the dallas cowboys where i wouldn't
be mad if they got something done you
know early on in the year before the
season starts wherever it may be is hey
he's he's a proven commodity at this
point you got to be careful the grass
isn't always greener on the other side
okay he has proven that he is a
franchise quarterback and yeah he might
not be patrick mahomes or aaron rodgers
or anybody like that but still he has a
big arm he is a big guy he's a very good
athlete he's phenomenal on and off the
field as a leader you never hear him
complain or make excuses he's a man's
man in a lot of ways that's what people
want at the quarterback position so uh i
would go if i'm the dallas cowboys i'd
try to find a way to pay the guy now
just i don't want to pay him
matt ryan aaron rodgers money you know
maybe kirk cousins jimmy garoppolo money
is where i think
a guy like dak prescott has to be
realistic about what he's asking for
we have been talking from time to time
in recent weeks about the possibility
that at some point a team will say to a
quarterback who is in line for a big
money deal no thanks there's a middle
ground though that i've kind of figured
out here and that is just let the guy
become a free agent and let him see what
else is out there or what else is not
out there and then you sign him to a
contract that is in line with what you
want to pay once he knows he's not going
to break the bank somewhere else
especially because you've got the weight
of the star yeah right everything that
goes along with being the cowboys
quarterback he's making more money off
the field now than he's making on the
field although he's trying to change
that he's set up to walk right into a
broadcast booth somewhere i mean look
there's former cowboys all over the
place in broadcasting once the football
career ends and i think that that if
you're not going to be offered something
dramatically more by another team you're
more inclined to stay with the cowboy so
that's another
option here it's sign him now it's wait
until next year and maybe play the
franchise tag game it's cut him loose
entirely and plan d would be
let him hit the open market and then go
out and sign him to a long-term deal
once he sees what the other teams may be
offering or not be offering yeah no i
that's a possibility i mean you're
certainly getting you're getting i guess
where i look at it from the team
standpoint which you risk in that
certain scenario is now the player being
a little disgruntled that the fact that
hey you drafted me i've done everything
right i've played hard uh you know
really you everything you've asked i've
done and you're not going to reward me
and you're gonna let me hit the open
market you know most players i think in
a lot of those type of scenarios too
they're gonna stick it to their old team
uh so that's where you got to be careful
too as far as an organization if you
know i really think you know i would to
a degree in a lot of ways oh you know
the cowboys offered me 30 million some
other team offered me 28 million well
screw the cowboys they had a chance to
do this a long time ago screw them i'm
going to go somewhere else for 28
million as long as the situation's okay
in your mind as far as you know the
offensive coordinator and you're
comfortable with all those things so i
would think that's what you worry about
risk-wise but i do think mike you bring
up an interesting conversation at all i
was going to talk about this a little
earlier you know again this the gm's
talking like dimitrov talking about the
money and he's surprised by the money
hey the gms are the ones that have
created this little issue to a degree
too not every next guy up on the
contract has to one-up the guy before it
to me that's where they've let the the
whole thing get out of hand when jimmy
garoppolo became 27 million and kirk
cousins became 28 million like what the
hell they don't deserve to be in the
conversation with some of the other
people they passed up you know we talked
about dexter lawrence you know with the
dallas cowboys you know to me some of
the teams to draw a line in the sand and
be like no this is khalil mack he's
better than you he's making this
i'm going to pay you a little less than
that because you're not khalil mack and
then you can pay some other people on
the roster too but to me that's where
things have gotten out of whack as far
as money and free agency a little bit
you meant to say demarcus lawrence sorry
and it's a different situation there
because he was signed while under the
franchise tag and they structured it the
typical way that a franchise tag
long-term deal needs to be done but your
point with quarterbacks makes a ton of
sense
it was it was it went three years with
aaron rodgers at 22 million in new money
per year top of the market and then
andrew luck
derek carr right matthew stafford jimmy
garoppolo kirk cousins matt ryan aaron
rodgers
russell wilson yeah ben roethlisberger
is the first one who didn't beat
the current guy ahead right new money
average and and uh yeah
zak prescott he's not going to beat
russell wilson none of these guys other
than patrick mahomes has a chance to
beat russell wilson so at some point the
cycle has to end
in in less than two years the market for
quarterbacks shot up that i say 10
million per year but i think part of the
problem is for several years
the quarterback market wasn't growing
commensurate with the growth of the cap
and you know the culprit there is tom
brady if tom brady had always insisted
on getting every penny that he's worth
to a team
the rubber band would be stretched so
far all these other quarterbacks would
have already fallen in line behind him
they wouldn't be making more than him
but it would be easier to get a bigger
percentage of the cap and because tom
brady has decided to reside in the mid
teens all these years that's made it
harder for these guys to get more money
but
that's a good point though
we we kind of reached the consensus uh a
a week or two ago that prescott i think
falls in the 25 to 30 million per year
range if they want to do it right the
broader point is this
jerry jones is putting the pressure on
them this year and for jerry jones it's
definitely a year to your proposition
and from his perspective look let's just
see how this year goes and uh i i think
that that
that makes it more sensible to wait to
pay dak prescott and wait to decide who
your coach is going to be yeah let's
focus on this [ __ ] let's give everybody
the ultimate carrot and or stick to have
a big season chris and if you don't then
you make your decisions after 2019 ends
yeah no i don't disagree i think you
said a lot of smart things there
certainly uh and we'll see how it plays
out i do i wonder if they will buckle
early with dak prescott and maybe throw
him change early in the year before we
really see how the season plays out
if he'll take it that's a question put
it out there and you see if he takes it
and he can he can want what he wants
it's one thing to say i want this i want
that it's another thing to know to say
no to what is right in front of you once
they put it on the table right that may
change everything
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports